[Music]
i'm just really excited to get to talk
about the ncis universe yeah and that
universe is coming back threefold that's
amazing thank you the entire franchise
made up of the og ncis los angeles and
newbie ncis hawaii returns with new
seasons this fall feels good to be on
something that's been road tested for 19
years
ncis and his pacific counterpart get
back-to-back premieres on september 19th
and hey how's this for a milestone we're
going to get together and celebrate this
thing that was created almost 20 years
ago the flagship series that started it
all is going on to its 20th season any
enemies do you like to disclose parker
i think it's been it's been
quite a magical experience to be able to
have these spin-offs with you know cast
and actors who who love the brand and
where we all can co-exist
it makes it very special because
sometimes they're more important things
than volunteers it just shows you how
far we've come and it's amazing that the
audiences have responded to it and to
think that i was a part of something
that began a franchise is pretty cool
yeah we think everyone wishes they could
chase bad guys in hawaii literally what
i do for a living but for vanessa lachey
stepping into her leading role was a
dream come true it's everything i've
worked for and literally dreamt of
having a show that i get to lead with a
great cast and a great crew and a great
studio network and so i'm um i'm feeling
very
grateful at this moment
oh that's not good we're just excited
new stunts new action i think the second
season is just going to be that much
stronger
back on the mainland ncis los angeles
premieres october 9th and the
franchise's first spin-off is coming off
a milestone of its own when we first
started i figured it'd be you know a
couple of years yeah try 13 years and
over 300 episodes maybe he just wants a
hug
i couldn't have dreamed of
you know what it is that we've done the
fact that we're going on to season 14 is
just it's surreal it's absolutely insane
[Music]